gestern eine regierungserklärung der
bundeskanzlerin heute die von ihnen
angesprochenen für zusatzpunkte das
thema corona maßnahmen gegen korona aber
auch hilfen für die durch corona bedroht
betroffen oder in mitleidenschaft
gezogen sind ist schon recht präsent im
deutschen bundestag aber die kritik
reißt in der tat nicht erbte seitens der
opposition vor allem das parlament komme
zu kurz es wird zu spät informiert die
regierung habe zu viel spielraum all das
wollen wir besprechen heute morgen denn
dafür ist und dafür sind wir auch in der
anfrage hierarchie ziemlich weit nach
oben gegangen was die fraktionen angeht
ich freue mich dass heute morgen bei uns
den britta haßelmann die erste
parlamentarische geschäftsführerin der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen und
michael grosse brömer ist bei uns der
dieselbe funktion hat eben der
fraktionen cdu/csu beschäftigen uns
gleich und umgehend mit den
aufgeworfenen fragen wollen aber fix auf
den allerersten tagespunkt
tagesordnungspunkt heute morgen gucken
nämlich die fortgeltung der epidemischen
lage nationaler tragweite her große
brömer wir haben einen
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz wir haben
einen infektionsschutzgesetz warum jetzt
noch dieser gesetzentwurf dieses gesetz
nun weil das parlament der selbstbewusst
ist der regierung ganz klar
vorzuschreiben wie sie sich zu verhalten
hat in dieser pandemie und das ist ein
weiterer beweis heute mit dem ersten
tagesordnungspunkt dass wir klare
vorgaben machen nämlich dass
verordnungsermächtigung eben nicht
unendlich gelten sondern nur für drei
monate das heißt im prinzip dokumentiert
dieser erste tagesordnungspunkt heute
morgen dass all die vorwürfe das
parlament säßen nicht sozusagen im
fahrersitz würde die regierung handeln
lassen ohne parlamentarisch vorgesehene
kontrolle abgesucht ist und deswegen bin
ich ganz froh dass wir uns heute morgen
unterhalten
sie sehen an der tagesordnung vielleicht
ein bisschen die hilflosigkeit der
opposition in der sache hat man nichts
deswegen arbeite man sich am verfahren
habe jetzt nimmt der relativ viel vorweg
also ich glaube das ganze geht vor allem
auch noch mal zu definieren welcher
zeitpunkt eigentlich für diese
epidemische lage gilt und dass das ganze
dann ungefähr im drei monats takt an
fortgeschrieben wird wenn die lage nach
wie vor so ist frose man es geht um die
fortgeltung dieser epidemischen lage die
regelungs verfahren sollen auch
überprüft werden durch die leopoldina
die akademie und die in vorahnung wird
auch eine rolle spielen ist doch top
eigentlich ja das ist zwingend notwendig
denn die pandemie liegt er jetzt schon
über ein jahr zurück daher beginn der
pandemie und seinerzeit waren es die
oppositionsfraktionen und unter anderem
bündnis 90 die grünen die gesagt haben
es abwegig die idee zu entwickeln das
die feststellung der epidemischen lage
bei der bundesregierung liegt wir haben
seinerzeit in gesprächen durchgesetzt
dass der deutsche bundestag die
feststellung der epidemischen lage
trifft und deshalb ist es auch jetzt so
dass der deutsche bundestag sich erneut
damit befassen muss liegt die
epidemische lage nach wie vor vor
daran gibt es ja keinen zweifel wir sind
mitten in der pandemie wir sind in der
pandemie bekämpfung aber es ist wichtig
dass wir hier druck gemacht haben denn
ansonsten hätte vielleicht die koalition
gerne diese entscheidung bei der
bundesregierung gelassen so sahen die
ersten pläne aus auf die frage der
befristung und der besonderen
begründungspflicht von rechtsverordnung
haben wir beim töten bevölkerungsschutz
gesetz durchgesetzt
ich glaube es ging weniger um die frage
was die koalition will sondern der
bundesgesundheitsminister wollte glaube
ich die fortgeltung der epidemischen
lage bis september wenn ich es richtig
im kopf habe was hat den ausschlag
gegeben jetzt das doch anders anzugehen
ja das ist erneut ein beispiel dafür wie
sich das parlament einmischt also das
ist ja eine stetige wechselwirkung
natürlich hat die exekutive also die
bundesregierung ihren job zu tun der
bundesgesundheitsminister genauso wie
die kanzlerin oder andere zuständige
minister das tun sie aber eben nicht
ohne uns zu beteiligen und da gibt es
manchmal unterschiedliche auffassungen
und da ist die frage wann wird die
fortsetzung der mission lage von
nationaler tragweite festgesetzt das
machen wir wir geben der regierung auf
wie lange sie sozusagen mit
rechtsverordnung die die flexibilität
ermöglichen die auch gebraucht wird in
einer pandemie wie lange die fortwirkt
also all das ist natürlich eine
kooperation und nicht immer setzt sich
der minister mit dem durch was er gerne
will
ein schönes beispiel für
parlamentarische selbstbewusstsein es
sollte man ein weiteres gremium geben im
deutschen bundestag auch initiiert
aus den koalitionsfraktionen ein
dieser ausschuss der sowohl die
information der fraktion verbessern soll
aber auch die mitsprache ist das nicht
auch ein wesentlicher schritt was die
parlamentsbeteiligung angeht wollen wir
mal sehen ob das kommen angekündigt wird
es schon länger und zwar weil es kritik
daran gibt dass wir außerdem beratungen
durch wissenschaftler innen die wir
jetzt haben die wir kennen das immer
einzelne hinzugezogen werden fordern wir
grüne ja seit monaten die einsetzung
eines interdisziplinären
wissenschaftlichen pandemie rates der
uns begleitet sowohl wissenschaftlich
interdisziplinär als auch gucken könnte
wo ist auch eine fehleranalyse notwendig
parlaments irgendwo oder auf nachdem wir
wollen den einsätzen mit expertinnen und
experten von außen und
selbstverständlich können in der
konstruktion auch parlamentarier innen
dort vertreten sein
seit monaten wird auf diese idee von
bündnis 90 die grünen immer wieder so
reagiert ja es keine schlechte idee aber
eingesetzt ist bis heute noch nichts
deshalb jeder schritt in diese richtung
ist wichtig und notwendig
der grosse brömer besteht um den
interdisziplinären ausschuss sie
interessen der spd scheinen weiter zu
gehen als ihre sie wollen ein breiteres
spektrum abbilden in diesem ausschuss
wie ist der stand der dinge und ab wann
kann dieser ausschuss möglicherweise
tätig werden
zunächst muss man mehr sagen dass all
diese beratungen ja auch schon in
erheblichem maße stattfinden wir haben
ausschussarbeit wir haben ein
gesundheitsausschuss der ich fast fast
die tage und wochen durch arbeitet also
dass da nichts passiert und dass da
keine experten angehört werden ist schon
jetzt nicht so aber da sag ich einmal so
nah wie eine koordinierung und der
koordination genau und wir hatten mal
ursprünglich angedacht dann
unterausschuss im gesundheitsausschuss
zu bilden nun diskutieren wir in der tat
mit der spd noch konkret wie die
ausgestaltung sein soll
ob man das jetzt ganz groß an legt mit
ethischen fragen verbindet oder ob man
ganz konkret am fall arbeitet mit dem
was ich persönlich die menschen betrifft
in deutschland
das diskutieren wir gerade noch aber wir
werden relativ zügig eine lösung
präsentieren das reicht nicht wir
brauchen interdisziplinär
wissenschaftlich externe begleitung und
zwar kontinuierlich von außen deshalb
die idee des pannen
es gibt das haben wir jetzt in dem
gespräch bislang ein bisschen
herausgearbeitet parlamentsbeteiligung
auf verschiedenen ebenen die ganzen
diese komplette sitzungswoche ist
vorgezogen worden weil mittwoch die
beratung stattgefunden haben die bunte
länder runde trotzdem sind sie nicht
zufrieden schon gar nicht mit den
abläufen
sie sagen es gibt erst die beschlüsse
und dann die regierungserklärung
es gibt erste empfehlungen und dann
beratung im parlament diese woche hätten
wir das ganz anders und ganz einfach
anders gestalten können
wir haben am mittwoch mit dieser
plenarwoche begonnen hier im plenarsaal
mit der öffentlichen debatte im
deutschen bundestag und wir hätten
selbstverständlich am mittwoch auch vor
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundeskanzlerin sagen können lassen wir
doch die bundeskanzlerin mal die im
parlament darlegen wie sieht denn die
bundesregierung die nächsten schritte
gegen dieser bekämpfung der pandemie
das ist nicht erfolgt das interesse war
nicht da man gegen zuerst in die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und
erzählte uns im nachhinein in der
aussprache worauf man sich verständigt
hat das ist nicht unsere vorstellung
davon wie parlamentsbeteiligung wirklich
aussieht ohne mühe wäre es anders
machbar gewesen dann könnte man
einerseits sagen wir wie die kanzlerin
denkt über die lage und wie die
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten darüber denken ist
nicht ganz unbekannt auf der anderen
seite ist der einwand der grosse brömer
ja richtig war eu-gipfeln beispielsweise
funktioniert es auch da ist die
kanzlerin morgens donnerstagmorgens oder
auch mal freitags hier im parlament
diskutiert dann über erhält eine
regierungserklärung diskutiert das thema
und vettern anschließend zu dem gipfel
warum nicht bei diesen themen warum
nicht bei dieser bund länder runde
das ist relativ einfach zu erklären weil
das koordinierungsrunde gibt das was da
stattfindet unter federführung der
kanzlerin unter einladung oder nach
einladung der kanzlerin ist ja kein
gesetzgebungsorgan sondern da wird
diskutiert und im übrigen sieht man ja
auch dass manche ministerpräsident zu
meinem leidwesen dann in ihren ländern
weil sie zuständig sind völlig andere
maßnahmen ergreifen
im übrigen ist es auch ganz lustig wenn
ich von den grünen höre man müsste vor
diesen treffen ja mal
regierungserklärung haben herr
kretschmann als grüner ministerpräsident
in baden württemberg hat noch nie vorher
eine regierungserklärung abgegeben
da wäre es ja gut wenn der mit guten
beispiel voran ginge aber ich will jetzt
auch gar nicht immer
auf die unschlüssigkeit der
argumentation hinweisen sondern auch auf
die rechtsstaatliche wir haben vorhin
gesehen wie viel stunden allein diese
woche wieder sieben letzte woche acht
wir haben jede sitzungswoche eine
regierungserklärung dass das parlament
nicht beteiligt ist es geradezu
lächerlich dieser vorwurf und in dieser
sache diese koordinierungsrunde das ist
das einzige was überbleibt man müsste
sich vorher erklären
ich meine das macht keiner bei der
kultusministerkonferenz oder bei
sonstigen ministerkonferenzen die ja
sinnvollerweise im föderalismus
stattfinden man spricht sich ab und dann
entscheiden ja auch die länder und die
länderparlamente und die sind auch
beteiligt in umfang in unterschiedlicher
art und weise aber tut mir leid diese
argumentation für nicht wirklich nicht
schlüssig danach war die kanzlerin hier
und das ist auch richtig so danach muss
sie sich erklären weil das parlament
kontrolliert die regierung sie ersetzt
sie nicht frau soll man also zum einen
ist es erstmal so baden württemberg hat
ein sehr gutes
parlamentsbeteiligungsgesetz davon
könnten sich viele etwas abschneiden
dass es während der pandemie entwickelt
worden und ich finde das sehr gut der
zweite punkt das parlament und beim
parlament liegen beratung öffentlicher
diskurs und auch entscheidungen und wir
haben hier viel mehr zu tun das ist auch
an den empfehlungen der mpk deutlich
geworden
wo ist die perspektive für menschen wo
ist der stufenplan
wir haben gesagt wir sind gesetzlich
bereit dies hier zu verankern im
deutschen bundestag die frage von
befristung von maßnahmen begründung von
master das kann doch jetzt nicht in
diesem kleinteiligen wir machen mal
heute eher einen öffnungs discos für
friseure
wir überlegen vielleicht am rande mal
wie kann die schule und bildung spektive
aussehen
wir haben eine klare noch immer
epidemische lager auch durch die
mutation eine risikoreiche lage aber die
menschen brauchen doch eine perspektive
und deshalb wäre es wichtig hier im
deutschen bundestag eine gesetzliche
grundlage für einen stufenplan zu
entwickeln
darauf drängen wir und nicht dieses
kleinteilige schritt für schritt
informieren wir mal das parlament
darüber was zu tun ist aber jetzt mal
unabhängig davon dass der bundestag
natürlich nicht entscheiden kann über
dinge die die länder dann betreffen
sie haben ja gerade auch dass die im
bereich bildung angesprochen es gibt
diese kultur so hat wo die länder
entscheiden können wie sie es machen
weil sie was ich jetzt auch tun worüber
meiner wieder auf einer anderen ebene
streiten kann
wäre denn eine variante wie sie jan
korte vorgeschlagen hat ihr kollege aus
der linksfraktion eine breitere
beteiligung der bevölkerung dadurch zu
erreichen indem man öffentliche
expertenanhörungen macht auch hier im
bundestag wir würden das locker live
übertragen werden hoch begeistert mit
der veranstaltung was ist denn mit
dieser idee her große brömer
expertenanhörung finden in diesem haus
täglich statt
natürlich auch zu der zu der frage wie
wir gesundheitspolitisch auf die
pandemie reagieren das ist doch gar
keine frage
nur ist es manchmal auch in einer
pandemie historischem ausmaß notwendig
wo man sagt ja nicht umsonst das ist die
stunde der exekutive dass eine regierung
handlungsfähig bleibt
und da muss man auch kurzfristig
reagieren können und das ist eben auch
wichtig sozusagen orientiert an der
entwicklung der infektionszahlen
ministeriell zu arbeiten von der
regierung von der regierung
entsprechende entscheidung abzufordern
das tun wir als parlament und die haben
ja auch gerade gesehen die kollegin hat
man war ja plötzlich auch nicht mehr bei
der parlamentsbeteiligung sondern sprach
da mal ein paar inhaltliche dinge an für
die die länder zuständig sind
das ist auch gut so dass auch aufgabe
der opposition deswegen bin ich ja
sofort dabei wenn man in der sache mal
vorschläge macht was man besser machen
kann
woran wir im zweifel auch bei stufen
plänen ja gerade arbeiten und teilweise
schon vorgeschlagen haben aber es bleibt
eben auch nicht mehr viel übrig wenn man
mal staatspolitisch und faktisch
argumentiert dann ist eben dieses
parlament nicht nicht beteiligt dann
wäre ich auch am am anfang der bewegung
sondern dann stellen wir fest dieses
parlament ist glaube ich europaweit und
weltweit das parlament das am
intensivsten mit dieser pandemie sich
beschäftigt und der regierung klar sagt
was sie tun soll
jetzt hätte ich gerne mit ihnen noch
diskutiert dass über die verordnung die
die minister treffen können ja
möglicherweise die parlament
das parlament sehr viel mehr
eingeschränkt wird oder im parlament
entscheidungen sehr viel mehr
weggenommen wird als über das vor über
die reinen verfahren geht aber nicht
der präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes gerade ein
gutes interview
deshalb werden die grünen sich auch
dafür stark machen dies zu ändern 859
und 30 sekunden eigentlich wollte ich
sie vor 30 sekunden schon geben lassen
damit sie dann gehen wir jetzt damit sie
pünktlich im plenarsaal mit vielen dank
für heute morgen ich fürchte den
debatten wir trotzdem weitergehen
44 ein für heute morgen ihnen beiden